we should have a human-centered AI
developed in Europe
[Music]
the European Parliament plans to
regulate artificial intelligence with
the intention to ensure that this
technology helps us for the better and
keeps us safe from the worse in a
nutshell what are the main points of the
AI act and what does it mean that it is
a risk-based regulation it's law that
can be enforced that can defend the
interests and the rights of citizens in
a in a higher level for sure the core of
this legislation the idea behind it is
the fact that we should have a
human-centered AI developed in Europe
that we should defend our values our
model and also build a dialogue with the
rest of the world around how we can make
AI compatible with democracy supportive
of
emancipation of of people of giving more
opportunities and not instead
create more fractures or fuel
disinformation or
create a control State what exactly
falls under the category of AI so AI in
in the view of of the parliament is to
recognize the fact that an AI has to
work with a certain degree of autonomy
and in the content that it generates it
has to be able to influence or capable
of influencing either virtual or
physical environments and that is the
key element that differentiates AI from
other type of software so whether we
look at applications that are in the
prohibition list to applications that
are in in high risk we have to first
make sure and differentiate and make
sure that it is indeed Ai and that it
comes indeed under the scope of the
regulation before we determine whether
it is one of those applications that
would be prohibited or not can you just
know that something falls under the AI
regulation by seeing how it works like
measuring this autonomy part companies
will self-assess and they will
self-assess on the basis of the
definitions that are in the text and the
criteria that are in the text and it is
then if their determination is that they
are in the category of high risk then
there are obligations that have to do
with transparency and indeed with
explainability which means that they
will have to explain what kind of data
they use to train the algorithm what
kind of instructions did they give to
the to the algorithms so on and so forth
we don't ask them to disclose the code
itself because that might even be
protected uh by law will there be an
office that would be
um where one could report possible
infringements if let's say a company
doesn't do self-assessment in the way
they should do it the issue of
flexibility of this legislation has
always been at the core of our attention
as you mentioned earlier the fact that
we focus on use cases it's important
rather than just on the technology
itself because this will make this
legislation more durable and less at
risk of obsolescence but at the same
time we have foreseen various degrees of
facilitation for the modification of the
areas that are under the high risk
classification
foreign
[Applause]